el juicio inició el ex ministro de
interior italiano matteo salvini tuvo su
primer cara a cara con la justicia que
lo acusa de secuestro tras su decisión
en 2019 que un barco con más de 100
inmigrantes a bordo no desembarcará en
su país al salir de la audiencia salvini
recordó que 12 países de la unión
europea pidieron crear muros para
controlar la migración y criticó el
proceso en su contra andará proceso
largo para con youtube ver su realidad
es surrealista someterse a juicio porque
he hecho mi trabajo me da pena porque
digo que es serio puede ser un juicio en
el que richard gere viene de hollywood a
dar testimonio de mi carrera espero que
dure lo menos posible porque hay cosas
más importantes que hacer que duren
menos posibles
los migrantes quedaron varados en el mar
durante casi tres semanas a bordo del
barco de rescate de la ong open arms
hasta que los fiscales ordenaron la
incautación del barco y la evacuación de
todos los que estaban a bordo
pero para salvini él solo hizo cumplir
la ley cuesta una nave piedra se trata
de un barco pirata que recogió
inmigrantes en aguas libias el primero
de agosto de 2019 y recogido inmigrantes
en aguas maltesas el 2 de agosto es un
barco que tiene derecho a llevar 19
inmigrantes a bordo y al final tenía más
de 150 de ellos que arribará a taberna a
bordo
550 si alguien ha cometido un delito y
ha puesto en riesgo la vida de las
personas es el comandante de este barco
pirata y no ministro que defendía a su
país con un ministro que adif eso para
esa serán más de 50 los testigos de este
proceso entre ellos ex ministros de
interior de italia el juicio continuará
el 17 de diciembre y de ser declarado
culpable por la justicia siciliana
salvini podría enfrentar hasta 15 años
de cárcel